desperately trying to revive their
Russia collusion talking points ahead of
this week's hearings with former Special
Counsel Robert Muller now even though
Muller didn't find any collusion and the
DOJ ruled there was no obstruction
Democrats refused to accept reality and
move on
for example House Judiciary Chairman
Jerry Nadler is saying the report could
provide evidence for impeachment the
report presents very substantial
evidence that the president is guilty of
high crimes and misdemeanors and we have
to present that or that Muller present
those facts to the American people and
then see where we go from there because
the administration must be held
accountable and no president can be can
be above the law House Intel chief Adam
Schiff is going even further by claiming
Trump could end up in jail lock him up
he is a essentially unindicted
co-conspirator he's been identified as
an individual one as the person who
directed Michael Cohen to commit this
fraudulent campaign scheme from my point
of view if the evidence supports that he
should be indicted and Texas congressman
Al Green not giving up on his
impeachment fantasy this president will
be impeached I am convinced of it I
believe my colleagues are moving in this
direction and I trust that it will
happen sooner rather than later the
president Trump responding by dismissing
the hearing as an attempt to resurrect
the witch-hunts I'm not going to be
watching probably maybe I'll see a
little bit of it I'm not going to be
watching Muller because you can't take
all those bites out of the Apple we had
no collusion no obstruction we had no
nothing we had a total no collusion
finding the Democrats were devastated by
it all they care about is a phony
investigation he's definitely not going
to be watching the Muller I enjoy most
about this presidency is the MSP 3,000
aspect where he really does live tweet
along with almost everything and I
really hope he does he shouldn't hold
back like this is the time and the place
for his impulsivity when he's digesting
things in real time but I you know you
were saying that the Democrats are
dusting off the Russian collusion
talking points they better skip ahead to
20
20 because the the Chinese are looking
at the Russians going amateurs we've
infiltrated the software we've done so
much more than that Huawei what do you
think that Huawei is the company that
your software and networking what do you
think the Democrats are living in the
past right now and it's time to move
forward I don't understand this I really
impress me well because I the president
is out there saying that Democrats and
and Muller can't have a second bite at
the Apple is gonna be bad for the
Democrats he's apparently alarmed as if
he's got something to hide I thought no
obstruction no collusion something - he
should be asking Muller's like a full
report
he should be asking Muller to stand up
and say exactly what's in the report
instead he's running like you know like
you know something's wrong oh I don't
buddy pay attention nobody home nobody
here he looked like he was sitting to
meet iris this is like Muller hearing
week listen through this whole process I
said I would go with moles report I'd
say you know like typically when an
investigation happens I like to get to
the end before I pass judgment I'm weird
that way and I don't think it was a very
straightforward guy I don't see him
saying anything different except maybe
turn to page 35 right you know for every
question 27 I think I answer that I
don't think this is gonna be a very
exciting day for either side I think
we'll just at the end of this we'll
learn that the Democrats think that he
committed high crimes and the
Republicans don't believe he did and
that's exactly will be at the end of the
day and he's not a very exciting person
but I think the most exciting part is
going to be the Republicans on the
committee asking some really tough
questions that Muller has not answered
absolutely Jesse when did you determine
there was no conspiracy
at what point after the last FISA
warrant renewal in June of 2017
you didn't renew it in the fall did you
find out then and why didn't you let the
American people know there was no
conspiracy before the midterm elections
why didn't you investigate the predicate
of the original counterintelligence
investigation what launched this can you
tell us that it's going to be a field
day for Republicans for the Democrats
Jerry Nadler is just trying to rustle up
some interest in impeachment because the
numbers have been falling 21% according
to the latest Wall Street Journal NBC
News poll the share of Americans in
favor of impeachment hearings 21% down
six points even down nine points to 39%
for the Democrats so he's trying to have
a dog and pony show only problem is no
dogs or ponies are gonna be there dogs
and ponies are awesome instead it's an
old rooster Bob Muller and a bunch of
Weeble wobbles no you know who's been
standing on one leg in the circus
digging bill bar bill bar absolutely
spun America and they said no
obstruction no collusion look that's the
case and by the way bill Barr said go
ahead mr. Muller testify that's the most
important thing then because if you have
some sort of a disconnect between what
the Attorney General said when he
summarized the report and the author of
the report special counsel Robert
Moeller then you know Republicans and
Democrats should really try and
reconcile but here's it but I think
that's very fair and I think we should
get to the bottom of that because we
deserve the truth right um the the thing
that's problematic for Democrats is what
dehghan is talking about I don't think
they're going to find anything new I
don't think they're going to jostle
Robert molars brain he's gonna go oh my
gosh you guys I totally forgot
and I meant to charge of anyhow if you
removed from office now Hillary flies in
but you know here's to that point here's
the real question I think Democrats
could ask and it's something that we all
want to know Republicans and Democrats
is the only reason that you chose not to
indict this president because of Justice
Department policy against and ighting a
sitting president and if that's the case
why didn't you talk to the president why
didn't you talk to Don junior why did
you make these could conclude John
junior didn't leave it to the militar
knowing that bill did walk what he Don
jr. spoke to this okay and I know the
president gave written answers not to
Mullen you yes you did when you are out
in the streets when you're out in the
bars when you're out with your people
when I'm out picnicking cherry trees
Sicily
no because the American people just like
myself and everyday Joe just a little
taller than everybody else we've moved
on from this and here's the thing molars
not going to read and that was the point
of the whole report he's not gonna make
new law and he's not gonna get personal
opinions so I think people wanted him to
say hey what would you do in that
situation he said based on the laws in
front of me this is my report he's gonna
and it's the same thing now if our rules
are different as far as what a sitting
president can and cannot do then we need
to look at that but he's not going to
create that's what the Supreme Court's
for and that's not mothers gonna do if
you read the model report and I read the
remodel report volume 1 volume 2 volume
2 at the end of the day no investigation
was obstructed not the FBI
counterintelligence investigation not
the Muller investigation 500 search
warrants no witnesses interfere with
they could interview anybody that they
wanted to even people in the White House
yes and to that point the big entree
remember was collusion and they didn't
find any conspiracy to collude with the
Russians to interfere in the election
and I think the rest of the countries
moved on wait a second they did find
many instances in fact more than a
hundred instances of contacts no not a
crook here's the point they didn't find
a conspiracy they didn't find anything
written and say okay this is so 100
percent locked in we don't and that the
Russians in fact wanted Donald Trump to
win but we can't lock it and that's all
but you know if I'm up there from the
congressman which I would say you know
if you're supposed to be looking into
Russian interference in the election
either
why didn't you not look into the Hillary
Clinton yeah but that's a fair question
so if you're talking about contacts from
Russians if that is the threshold one
there were a lot of Russians who had
contact with a person that was being
paid millions of dollars by the DNC and
if it's problematic to have Russians
giving someone information in order to
affect the outcome of an election that
has to be problematic is
we're going to be consistent dizzy
because clearly you know what fusion GPS
is an American company and you can hire
an American company to do whatever you
want they can go to the Russians and say
oh that's different than having Vladimir
Putin on the line let me write President
Obama What did he say to him cut it out
next